- We have reached the end of the hour,
but I have one more story to share.
This is what I'm liking.
(theme music)
Sometimes it can feel like kindness is
in short supply, but
a social media star is
out to prove otherwise.
Known as Jimmy Darts
he rewards total strangers with money
for simple acts of caring.
- How much for the brooms?
- I got one for six, or two for ten bucks.
- Do you think you'd be
able to do one for five?
- One for five?
- Yeah, all I got is five on me right now.
- Yeah man, lets do it
- Really?
- Thank you.
Gosh, well guess what? I
got $1000 here for you.
- Oh, wow.
- Thank you, thank you
- You're welcome
- Can I give you a hug?
- Yes, yes
- Bless you
(applause)
- That's so cool. Lets get Jimmy in here,
watching on NBC, Los
Angeles. What's up Jimmy?
(applause)
- Hey, what's cooking
Kelly? How you doing?
- Oh my God, I'm trying not to cry.
Every time I watch your videos I cry.
Um, so you weren't always
making these types of videos,
so what changed?
- Yeah, I mean, uh, back in the day,
I was doing wild party videos and then,
when I was 18 years old, um,
I really just met the love
of Jesus, changed my life
- Huh.
and from then on I just wanted to,
like, help other people,
restore other people,
bring redemption to their lives,
and I started making these kindness videos
and, uh, it's it's just
been an absolute blast
We've changed so many lives,
and it's just every day waking up.
It's just so fun to go outside.
- Man, what have you...
(applause)
that's incredible, by the way, um,
but what have you
discovered about yourself,
or about just people in
general, like doing this?
This is such an amazing
thing you do for others.
- Yeah, I mean I think people are amazing.
Like when I go out and do
these videos a lot of times,
people say, "How many people
did you ask for help?",
and most of the time, it's
the first person I asked
that helps me. That gentleman,
Sebastian, you just played
in the video. He was a
blind broom salesman,
and his dream was to be a car salesman.
No one was gonna give him a shot.
No one was gonna give
him a chance at the job.
Well, one of my followers saw the video,
says we got a car dealership, we'd love
to come offer him a job, so we show up
with all my followers, surprise him
We raised $100,000 for him in 24 hours
and then my friend, who
has a dealership, hires him
as a car salesman, and he's
already sold, like, 5 cars
in his first week, so it's unbelievable.
(applause)
- Oh my gosh, like, Jimmy. You're actually
creating real change in the
world. What an amazing set
of footprints you're
leaving behind my man.
I'm so grateful to have you on the show.
Thank you so much, I'm
liking your post right now
(applause)
- Oh, baby. All right,
take care. Bless you,
and it's been a pleasure.
- Well, that's not all, actually.
Our season long partner Pilot pen makers
of Frixion, to go to raise for pen
of the Kelly Clarkson show, want
to celebrate those creating and
then making a difference,
just like you man
so their gonna give you $1000,
and you can put that
towards helping more people
(applause)
- Oh baby, lets go. That's amazing.
We'll make sure to change someone's life.
- I'm just over here
trying not to cry, Jimmy.
(chuckles)
I like those videos,
whew! All right, thank you
so much Jimmy, and thank you
to all our guests this hour
Jim Anfuso, and also Miranda Cosgrove
and Chance the Rapper, Faye and Paul.
Y'all have a great day, and
if it's not try and change it.